all right guys
bang bang i've got anna here thank you
so much for doing this
thank you for having me absolutely let's
jump right into your background uh
you're a reporter at reuters today but
kind of what did you do before
you started writing about fintech uh
actually i was
i started writing about fintech seven
years ago so it's been
kind of mostly of what i've done um i
used to work at a paper called financial
news here in london
and it's owned by dow jones so it was
part of the journal franchise
um and when i got hired there um i
started on the online beat which meant i
didn't have a really have a beat
and it was early fintech days so that
was up for grabs the
sort of beat reporters didn't think it
was much because the deals were small
and i thought it made sense to cover i
thought it was you know going to be
bigger
um in finance because like every other
industry you know digital was
was coming in so i started writing about
that and then we changed editor the
editor really believed in in that area
and so we
started writing more about it and then
it sort of exploded and then i moved to
reuters
i'd previously interned at reuters in
brazil for a bit where i was covering
markets
um so it was good because i had the sort
of finance background
which i think was a good differentiator
at the start often you have like fintech
reporters who have tech backgrounds and
i think it's important to have the
the finance understanding to cover this
in the right way
absolutely and explain a little bit just
like when
people hear that you cover fintech what
exactly does that cover kind of where
are the boundaries
uh because it's so kind of pervasive
yeah when i started i was only doing
wholesale fintech so like capital
markets technology that sort of thing
whereas now it's like really everything
it ranges from you know
uh from crypto but also peer-to-peer
lending or even just you know the tech
side of banks and you know the tech
operations or trading applications you
know
so the whole of like if you think of
finance and technology like
really all of it so it's kind of
incredibly broad and my remit is now
global so it's even broader
but it's fun because you can you know
write about um
you know central bank digital currencies
or then you can move on and write about
like fintech apps for children it's just
like the whole
the whole space absolutely and so i
wanted to get you to jump on real quick
because
uh you broke the news last week that
paypal is jumping into
uh cryptocurrencies maybe talk a little
bit just about you know
when you started to hear about this and
kind of how you got the confirmation
that this was actually happening
so i got the confirmation because they
spoke to me it was it wasn't very
i've had more more hard to get stories
in this case
um so you know i i frankly i know
there'd been
there'd been a story i think a couple
months ago from coindesk about it right
um so it wasn't completely shocking to
me but i was still surprised
um because you know they're a big
company i've been covering them for a
while because i was
i mean i just moved back to london but i
was in the us i would cover their
earnings frequently
and i remember in 2016 or seven i think
2017 early 2017 i'd interviewed dan
shulman
um it was like a sort of he came into
reuters and it was lots of reporters and
editors and he
and he said you know crypto doesn't have
much utility yet so
i really didn't think that they were
looking at this obviously it's been
many years since but it was still
surprising although you know once i
heard more about it what they were doing
and i thought about it some more i spoke
to people it kind of
made more sense for them to do something
like this
yeah and explain kind of what exactly
are they doing so
they're gonna for starters are gonna
allow people to buy and sell
crypto and it's four right it's bitcoin
litecoin bitcoin cash and ether
um but i think what maybe was lost on
some people is that they're not gonna
let you buy bitcoin and you're actually
holding your bitcoin and you can sort of
move it and do whatever you want
you're buying bitcoin but you can't move
it away from their wallet
you'll be able to spend um within the
paypal network which is a massive
network but still you won't be able to
just buy a bitcoin with
paper and then send it to your friend
who has a coinbase account you know
so it's it's slightly different than
what you might expect
um but you know the massive thing as i
said is that from start of early next
year or like by mid
next year you'll be able to shop with
their merchants
um so that that could add a lot of
utility to bitcoin
absolutely and what i didn't understand
uh kind of when i saw the news break
is uh how big paypal is right so the
numbers i read it's got like 340 million
users
it's got 25 plus million merchants um
and then
uh it looks like they're either the 20th
or 30th 30th largest quote unquote bank
by the number of deposits and so this
thing is um
everyone knows the paypal brand but it's
just massive when you look at those
numbers
i think that the thing about paypal is
you know they've been around
for a fintech company they've been
around for a long time so i think
people just think oh paypal it's there i
mean but but they've
ever since they spun out of ebay they've
been really growing a lot and they have
a very interesting strategy of just
partnering with everyone
um and so they have partnerships with
all the bank
the credit card providers and and you
know so so it's not surprising
that they would find another you know
way to fund the accounts
it's part of who they are now like this
idea of partnering with more company
with more companies and different forms
of payments
and yeah they're massive i think i
remember when i was writing the story i
wrote that they had done i think
i don't want to make a mistake but i
think it was like around 200 billion in
payment volumes
in one quarter and i kept going back to
check because i was like billion
am i that's that's a lot per quarter are
we sure that it's not like
per year but yeah they're gigantic and
they're everywhere so
that's another big differentiator right
they're absolutely everywhere
absolutely and then talk a little bit
about venmo as a part of this right i
think venmo may be kind of the the
younger generation
kind of the newer brand but it sounds
like they also have some crypto plans
for venmo as well
yeah so they're gonna add this
capability to venmo again i think
by mid by mid-year or something like
that but in 2021 i don't remember the
dates exactly
and i hadn't thought about this very
carefully immediately as i wrote the
story but
they've been trying so they bought them
when they bought braintree
i think demo came with it again i hope
i'm not making too many mistakes but
it wasn't created by them it was
acquired so envemo is free and it's been
really popular with everyone like it's
just everyone has it in the us
um but it doesn't make a lot of money
right so they've been trying to make it
generate some revenue at the same time
they've seen like increased competition
from cash app
and cash up has been allowing bitcoin
purchases for a while
so it kind of makes and they've been
seeing how cash up has been making quite
a lot of money from bitcoin so it makes
sense that they might see this as a way
to jump help
them more generate some revenue and
become a bit more self-sustainable
so you know it makes sense and then you
have a younger sort of
type of profile of people in venmo so
you know it's smart
for sure it makes complete sense and um
what was interesting to me is uh kind of
you wrote the original article right
saying hey this is happening everyone
goes wild
uh in kind of the bitcoin and crypto
world um which is got to be a unique
experience i'm sure most of your
articles don't have these rabid fan
bases
kind of so it's very funny like when you
write a
positive like a story that's not even
like i mean it's positive for bitcoin
but i wasn't saying
bitcoin's gonna hit the moon like you
get so much new followers and then if
you do
spend like six months working on an
investigation about a crypto project
you just get haters and like your
followers decrease
so i think every now and again i'm just
supposed to tweet out a very positive
story
just tweet the word bitcoin and you'll
you'll be a fan favorite for sure
um in terms of uh the reaction from the
market so not kind of the the twitter
verse if you will but the actual
kind of financial players uh it looked
like you got kind of a mixed response
right because there was articles where
people were saying hey look this is a
big deal
and this is something to pay attention
to but then you also had an article
where there were some experts saying
like
and you know it's interesting but it's
not really going to have that material
of an impact maybe talk a little bit
about that balance
yeah so obviously the first reaction was
like
this is great for bitcoin and i and i
imagine that it would send the price
higher up because
in effect like there's been many big
companies that have tried to give
utility to bitcoin
so you know dell was one that i'd spoken
to in 2017 and they quietly rolled it
back
and then you know there have been ways
to pay with
bitcoin but there's this big tension
between you know bitcoin as a
way to invest in bitcoin as a way to
spend um
so originally like the price went up but
then i was speaking to sort of experts
in digital payments and many of them
were saying you know what
it's not clear that this will be great
for bitcoin
um or it or more not really great for
bitcoin but great for bitcoin as a form
of payment right because it could still
be that
first of all first of all there's that
closed loop thing that we talked about
before right where you're not really
able to take it out of the paypal
network so
it has a limited effect on the whole
market and then
also like people might not want to spend
it anyways because if you think that the
price is going to go up why are you
going to buy something with it right
you're going to keep
it but what they were saying is that it
might actually have more impact for sort
of
digital currencies in general and that's
what also paypal was telling me that
they're doing it because
they want to get and give more utility
to cryptocurrencies but they also want
to prepare for when there are central
bank digital currencies and that's sort
of what the experts were some experts
were telling me saying you know this is
pretty smart because they're positioning
themselves ahead of everyone else
um if this starts to happen if if you
know you see the euro
the sort of crypto dollar or the virtual
euro or
you know then they've already have that
integrated within
their system um so yeah so it might not
have seemed
it might not be have that huge impact as
you think but i think it's sort of
undeniable that it's brought it more
you know it's making it more mainstream
because now people who have a paypal
account they might have already paid
attention to bitcoin but it just shows
up right so it isn't
you know even just image wise it's a big
deal
absolutely and talk a little bit about
central bank digital currencies right
you have kind of this unique position in
the market where your job is literally
to go talk to as many people as possible
and kind of always know what's happening
what are you hearing on
the central bank digital currency side
either from market participants or maybe
even central bankers themselves
so i think there everyone's really busy
and there are many projects going on
but i have sort of this existential
doubt i don't know if it's
if it's like the blockchain enterprise
blockchain projects in early days
i'm trying to figure that out is it just
you know everyone's saying we're doing
something
out of like a knee-jerk reaction from
libra right they freaked out libra do we
want a private
social network who maybe had a hand in
like messing up elections to sort of now
decide
like to have power over like the global
currency
so they all said they were doing stuff
and there are some projects that are
live but i don't know
i think it's crucial to see like will
they be used and you know
even like the bigger currencies how long
will it take and like will they have
will they look at all like crypto or not
really would they just be
something different but there's
definitely more people talking about it
yeah
for sure and it feels like um one
perspective of the world
and you're kind of alluding to this
earlier is like somebody like a paypal
uh event eventually gets everyone a
digital wallet inside their system so
whether you're a user or merchant
whatever
uh today that's for cryptocurrencies uh
bitcoin etc
but eventually if central bank digital
currencies become real you already have
the infrastructure there
and it almost feels like the switching
cost between
uh going from bitcoin to central bank
digital currency and back
that friction will be so low uh and they
can use the same infrastructure for
everything
yeah i think i think that's the point i
think but i think there's
the central bank digital currencies are
work in progress so i don't know how
much they can like work ahead to know
what infrastructure
they'll need there was a story from i
think bloomberg towards the end of
friday or
maybe thursday about paypal buying bitco
or
talking to buy so that that's very
different right because then they would
be cus
like the idea i suppose is that they
want to be able to custody these things
so then it would be slightly different
from you know
what they've set up now but they've
they've said that it's sort of a work in
progress and they want to have like
interoperability between wallets so i
think it all remains to be seen
and also like as i mentioned you know i
mentioned libra
sort of paypal wasn't early it was a
founding member and they were the first
ones to leave so i wonder how much of
this is sort of uh
a reaction to that right to you know
they believed in the idea of digital
currencies but they didn't
like the way that was going so they've
still decided to go ahead in their own
way
yeah one of the things i don't know the
answer to but but it's interesting to
think through is
uh facebook kind of very courageously
came out they were the first company to
really spearhead this idea of like a
private currency
but still centralized in nature in terms
of there was a company where you could
call in
the ceo or call in somebody that was
running the project
and it was a brand that was recognizable
i wonder because of the government
response both in the united states
and elsewhere if that kind of scared a
lot of these companies away and they
basically are now saying uh
we probably can't do the private
currency thing so we might as well just
use the existing kind of decentralized
versions
yeah and speaking to sort of don
schulman from paypal he was very much
talking about how they've been speaking
to regulators we've been working with
regulators like he said regulators very
many times and it
and to me to be fair i was quite
surprised that there were like
i think it was mastercard visa and
paypal where the big financial companies
in that
because considering how the project was
announced there was very little clarity
on
you know if they've gotten if they'd
gone go ahead from regulators which in
the end they had it so i was surprised
that companies that are already like
big financial companies and are aware of
like the sort of massive
you know um input from regulators that
you need to have that they just jumped
in without
like checking with anyone before and so
in the end you know they left so
it you know i think now they probably
yes as you say they're probably thinking
we're gonna go ahead but
you know we're gonna do it with
governments and you know they're a lot
more cautious
absolutely you um you don't just write
about crypto bitcoin
um you write about fintech in general
what are some of the other fintech
trends that you're seeing kind of play
out as
kovid and all of that impact plays so
obviously there's a sort of digital
payment
side of things which is partly crypto
but like more
broad you know there's been a massive
upsurge in digital payments and digital
banking
in general because of lockdowns globally
so we're seeing more activity there
and more companies sort of growing and
also reaching big valuations
and it's generally one of the i guess
biggest trends
um and then also like online trading is
also growing you know we've seen like
robin hood and the like uh have an
explosive year so that's something else
that
we're watching uh and then in general
you know from the bank perspective also
you know they they're all
in the process of transforming digitally
but now
because they've had to shut down their
branches they had to and also like their
offices if you think about the whole
state's
wholesale side of the business they've
obviously they're telling us that
they've had
to accelerate the pace of digital
transformation um
and if you know things that would have
taken them a month or two months they
did it like two days
um so overall it's like i guess it's
been great
for fintech generally obviously there
have been areas that are
not doing great with like lending uh
clearly it's a bit of a
rough moment for lending because you
know lots of people are having a very
tough time
so you know people are expecting more
loan
losses absolutely and it feels almost
like uh kind of the financialization of
everything is
upon us right you're getting kind of any
company that touches money which is
almost every company
somehow they're starting to play in this
like fintech type world
um and then the fintech companies are
also becoming much more pervasive in
terms of
it used to just be hey we want to have a
neo bank right but now we're seeing
brokerage we're seeing cards we're
seeing kind of the the
software companies trying to almost eat
the traditional financial
system how do you kind of balance this
in your head is it going to be
where uh people are going to come from
different perspectives but everyone's
going to end up in just this digital
finance world so it doesn't matter if
you're a wall street incumbent a
technology company a crypto company like
we're all headed to the same place
i think so i think inevitably slowly
it's going to end up
being more like that i think obviously
there's always going to be
you will always need a little bit of a
physical presence because i mean for for
consumers you think less about it but if
you're a small business and you take
cash i mean it's
unless cash disappears but for for a
while you'll still need to have a little
bit of an out physical outpost right
but yeah it's i find it interesting that
you have like big tech finance tech
firms coming in and doing finance things
you know
like apple doing the apple cart with
goldman and then you have like the spin
techs that were like as you say you had
robin hood saying we're just a brokerage
and then they started launching an
account
or you know welfare doing the same or
sofi doing trading you know it's it's
just
everybody doing everything and it's
funny because early days of fintech was
unbundling
and now i guess they figured out people
don't want to have 50 apps on their
phone
for their financial life and so we have
a big rebounding of fintech and
i guess the winners will be who wins the
rebundling i suppose and some banks the
bigger ones in the us who have all the
money they need to
become more digital they'll probably
still remain winners i don't
see like them disappearing in the short
term but
you know the smaller fintech some of
them might not be able to
remain sustainable right yeah it's
really interesting too i think to think
through
um kind of the geographic boundaries
that were really prevalent
in uh kind of the legacy financial world
those seem to be going away a little bit
as well
because in the digital world uh yes you
should have to pay attention to the
regulations but
uh when you don't have to have a
physical location it makes it much
easier to kind of go other places right
and kind of have this
like cloud-based solution yeah it
definitely is
only i think the regulation is sort of
like
undeniable and something that stops you
more than anything right because
you know you need a license to be
somewhere else right and you need to
have
and that license maybe comes with rules
about having people there so
whereas you know like other types of
tech like tick tock can like take over
the world and like
i sweat six more i don't even know when
they were launched but
you know you robin hood was supposed to
come to the uk but decided not to
because i think the step of expanding in
another country when you're a financial
company
in another country when you're a
financial company is just that much
harder right so
um so it's it's going to happen but i
think slowly i think probably what's
happening is that
globally we're all becoming more similar
in the types of services we use like
everybody's becoming more
like and i guess it depends
like developed and developing markets
but you know we're all using the same
types of services but they're more
still a bit more localized right there's
the equivalent of robinhood somewhere
else and
and so forth right absolutely yeah and i
think that jack dorsey kind of
highlighted this the best right i heard
him one time say
uh what really excites him about bitcoin
specifically is this idea of
with uh square and cash app if he wants
to go into a new country
he has to do all sorts of things around
banking regulations getting people on
boarded kyc aml like you know
really really in-depth kind of legacy
type stuff he's like with bitcoin it's
immediately available in that new
country
right and now yes there's probably going
to be more regulation over time around
it but
i think that was a really unique
perspective from somebody who's kind of
playing in both worlds right
he's a big proponent of bitcoin but he
also understands uh kind of the
bureaucracy and pain of moving a legacy
company kind of country by country for
expansion yeah i mean i
i'm kind of like pretty you know having
covered finance also broadly for so long
i just think the
the regulatory part is inevitable and
like if the more
like you know widespread you get the
more you're gonna have like
controls around it if you see in the uk
they've now like you can't i think it's
with derivatives you can't retail
investors can't touch crypto derivatives
so it's
it's just the way of things right
because you need to protect some
consumers and not others so
i think it's true i think maybe crypto
has sort of given people the impulse to
realize that
stuff needs to be a bit more swift and
quick and you need to
have better ways of doing things whether
that translates in
the existing cryptos taking over the
world or
just new forms of like payments
improving then
you know that that remains to be seen i
guess
absolutely before i let you go i ask
everybody the same two questions
uh and then you'll get to ask me one to
finish up uh the first one is what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
oh no this is very hard um
[Music]
oh i don't know i can't i can say which
ones i liked that i keep thinking
okay i don't know um
[Music]
even two or three of them just ones that
come to attack i i
i'm so bad with questions like this it's
when they ask me like what are you
working
on i don't remember um
i love i mean these are not like
business books though it's fine
okay it's gonna be like really banal but
i loved americana
like still one of my favorite books um
why did you like that one
i just loved it i just thought it was
like so smart and like it touched on
like really
important topics but it was just like
love it was just a lovely read also on
top of everything yeah very well written
yeah
yeah um god
i loved um oh i don't remember the name
it was the one about a journalist and he
started working
in silicon valley for a bit and he was
doing content i think it was disrupted
maybe it was called i don't remember the
name i don't remember
no it's really a bad book recommendation
and i'm so bad with remembering things
but it was great because it was just
like
i think being a journalist it was like
looking inside
uh sort of the startup world from within
as a journalist so it makes me think
will i ever want to work in a startup i
don't know because look at this guy what
happened like it was just i just loved
it it was very funny obviously if i
remember the name it was better i
remember the cover but not
the name and then i think i also liked
um one of in just general michael lewis
books i think the early ones
yeah yeah i just i just like those
they're fun but they're also about
finance so you learn
things yeah yeah he's one of the best
for sure
uh second question is a little bit more
fun which is aliens are you a believer
or non-believer
i don't know i i'm a believer
i'm a believer i am a non-believer until
i see evidence to say that i haven't
seen sufficient evidence to believe
i also don't really think about it very
much i'm like too
worried about everything going on in the
world other worlds
that's probably the best reason to not
be worried about what's going on off
earth right as we got enough
problems here yeah yeah i love it uh you
could ask me one question to finish up
what do you got for me
what would be your dream guest like the
one you'd like love to have but it's
almost impossible
oh it will obviously have to be somebody
who's dead
um i would say
one of the people i've been fascinated
with my whole life and i don't know
where this fascination came from
uh is john rockefeller i think that
would be a really interesting
conversation especially
in uh if if we had all of the hindsight
clarity that we have now about what he
did how he did it
what he built how important oil became
kind of you know all of that
and then to be able to ask him like hey
man
tell us all this stuff like why did you
do this how did it work you know would
you go back and change anything
those types of questions i think would
be really fascinating for somebody who
you know one amassed a great fortune but
two did it in a
in a very kind of um uh it did it in a
way that i think today a lot of people
try to emulate in terms of like
standardizing industries and kind of
building these very powerful
uh almost monopolistic type type
companies
do you think you'd be a bitcoin believer
yeah i tend to think that a lot of those
early people weren't uh weren't the
biggest fans of
uh of kind of centralized planned uh
type of
currencies so yeah i
or maybe that's my bias just telling me
that they would be but uh but yeah him
jp morgan
et cetera i think uh you know they tend
to be a little bit more uh disruptive
and innovative than uh
yeah where um where can we send people
to find you
uh on the internet or find some of your
work so
you can follow me on twitter at an idea
so my name last name
and then my stories are on reuters.com
but i'll put i post everything so
the twitter is the easiest way twitter's
the best one all right listen anna thank
you so much for doing this i think that
uh
people are really fascinated with the
paypal news and uh
obviously uh you got the story out first
which is always uh
as well so thanks for doing this and
watching it again thank you thank you